he's changing the game he's changing the
game i think
um you know he's he's
shining light on on the new wave of
quarterbacks and
it's just it's just fun to watch and not
only that you know he has a lot of merit
to to what he does it's not like he's
just back there just an
arcade game as sometimes it looks like
it but he knows exactly what he's doing
and how he's manipulating the defense
and you know that's
that's the same thing that the dan
marino's used to do the obviously the
tom brady's the aaron rodgers
you know those guys really have so much
command of the offense that
you know you dictate to the defense and
um you know that's what he's doing he's
playing the game at a high level
so that's cam newton talking about his
counterpart on sunday
uh patrick mahomes earlier michael you
talked about
lebron's intentional comments there was
a lot of intentionality with cam
newton's compliments uh toward patrick
mahomes i was glad
to see him um
highlight and emphasize
the sophistication with which patrick
mahomes plays a position i mean
you know he can be likened his command
of the offense and his manipulation of
the defense to
to dan marino to you know to tom brady
certainly
neither of whom possessed a fraction of
the athleticism that patrick mahomes has
and so
i think cam newton especially look
knowing from experience how much people
can look at a
quarterback who plays with a high level
of athleticism and mobility
and and uh it failed to recognize
the damage that he does as a passer from
the pocket especially let's call it what
it is especially black quarterbacks
you know and so of course for cam newton
to to intention
i appreciated how subtle but nonetheless
significant it was for him to say look
it's not all
just fun and games he's making it look
easy but he's really using his mind
as much as he is using his physical
gifts and the changing the game part i
think is also
fascinating michael because you know
my son is outside i could look at him
right now and i'll in our driveway
um my son got a mean step back jumper
you know uh where'd he get that from
where'd he go now for me uh he got it
from watching james harden
and like a lot of kids uh you know of
this generation this younger generation
they've been inspired by steph curry you
know they all want to be steph they all
want to get out there
and shoot threes and and you know shoot
pull up threes or step backs like james
harden
i think what what patrick mahomes is
doing especially when you factor in
the you know his the mental game that
cam newton is is talking about what
patrick mahomes is doing is making it
even cooler if it's possible
to not just play quarterback but to
point to bring a flare
to the position yep that was often
that that was often frowned upon that
flair and that freewheeling
approach to the position was often
frowned upon because it was like oh you
know you got to stay within the system
it's got to be one two three back foot
let it go you got to go through your
progression a certain way
what what what mahomes is doing is
saying and i think you'll see a lot of
people
emulate it coming up they may not have
his arm strength they may not be able to
do what he does he's naturally gifted
but when you combine fundamentals with
you know
uh his style i think you'll see a lot of
people playing the position in a way
that back in the day would be considered
i don't know out of control or reckless
i think he is very much changing the
game yeah um
i'm not sure he's changing the game i
think
uh i think the game has how about this
he hasn't he's not changing the game i
think the game has changed
and that they have come around that
these these team builders
uh general managers and coaches have
come around and accepted
that there are many ways to quarterback
a football team
so i mean let's think about black you
mentioned it earlier think about the
black quarterbacks we've seen
since 2000. we've seen so many different
styles you know
so michael vick is one style michael
vick
donovan mcnabb is another style even
like some of the black
backups or black journeyman quarterbacks
like aaron brooks and jeff blake
you know those guys uh the late steve
mcnair that's one style kind of like
bully ball there
like a a bowling ball uh back there in
the pocket an mvp
in his own right in 2003. cam newton is
one style
and then there have been black pocket
quarterbacks so
the black quarterback has there is
diversity in that it's not just
oh you're you're black and you play
quarterback that must mean
you're a runner and not a passer
right i mean we've we've just seen that
thing just
totally explode even now in the game
like lamar jackson it's not like desean
watson
they're not similar you know pat mahomes
uh
it's not like kyler murray i mean it's
just a it's a
completely different view of these
quarterbacks so
i don't see anything from pat my homes
that i haven't seen before
i just like that he's in this moment
this opportunity
quarterback who can
you have you see something that you
haven't seen before
nobody's done it like this like this
and what is that define i'm saying
this i'm saying the the only guy
the only other guy is aaron rodgers for
me i told you before i thought i think
aaron rodgers is the best
performer at the position that i've ever
seen
um give me steve young's peak in terms
of execution
in terms of precision okay brady's the
goat give me steve young's peak
in the early mid 90s uh before he got
hurt
but in terms of just playing the
position
to make all the throws uh to improvise
to read defenses it's been aaron rodgers
for me
it's the best i've ever seen do it i
think patrick mahomes when you combine
again his creativity that's what we're
talking about the other day when i said
he was the contra code
he combined his creativity with his arm
strength
with his mind like patrick mahomes
you know arm strength arm talent as they
say
um to be able to throw from different
angles patrick mahomes can get as much
velocity
you know with his feet set overhand as
he can no look sidearm
i mean the stuff that he like the stuff
he's able to do with the football
it's hard for me to remember somebody
doing it quite like that
with the efficiency there are people
like you know elway look
john elway i mean you're talking about
robocop that's right
well you were saying john elway we were
talking about that i thought
i thought elway but john elway is the is
robo quarterback in the lab and maybe
this is where i bring in your point just
now about the way the game has changed
because elway never did it with this
kind of efficiency
that mahomes is doing it maybe that's
more of a function of the way the game
is played right now
as opposed to the way it was played in
the 80s and 90s with john elway
but if you if you're talking about
physically a quarterback it looks like
john elway
um yeah but when i say when i say he's
changing the game i'm thinking i'm
talking about when i see a guy
look it ain't for everybody you know how
you say okay kids don't try this at home
and if everybody i see a guy throwing an
underhand and sidearm and no look
um you know and and and fake jump
passing it
i do see somebody who's introducing
again
style with substance that typically the
nfl and right
you're right maybe they're just catching
up to it typically has frowned upon
when it comes to court to coaches
wanting their wanting a position to be
played
with a certain discipline with a certain
level of control and precision
he's he's what do you think that changed
he's he's literally fun to watch
what do you think that changes michael
by the way not not just black and white
traditionally even white quarterbacks
who are scramblers
hey you got to be able to play it from
the pocket josh allen for example
yeah he's extended the pocket from
sideline to sideline josh allen has
but what i'm saying is when do you think
that changed where
coaches and general managers is it
starts with the general manager because
a lot of guys well i guess it's hand in
hand a lot of general managers say
i can't i can't bring this guy to my
coach and coach says hey don't bring me
a player don't play don't bring me a
player like that
don't don't bring me that don't ask me
to code that but i i would say didn't
have that changed in the last what did
you say 10 years
yeah i don't know i mean it did maybe
more it depends on who you ask
because i mean it wasn't that long ago
when a hall of fame general manager and
i had to just you know
take one guy he got but bill pauling was
like hey
put him at receiver time lamar jackson
dude do not get me started on bill
pauline don't get me started
it's friday don't have me going on bill
pullman today um
but he said it and he got shouted down
who agree with you
maybe publicly but but there would be
there are people who probably
behind closed doors maybe thought the
same thing i mean
lamar jackson ain't the first
quarterback um to be
that they suggested hey maybe you should
take reps at receiver at the combine you
know what i mean
so i guess what i'm saying is i don't
know that it's been that recent
that the attitudes have changed again
not a black white thing i'm strictly
talking about the nature of the position
and how the position is played
remember when they remember the read
option they thought the read option was
a fad
that cam newton cam newton comes in and
is like oh no no this is this is what
we're doing this you know this is this
is here to stay
and so uh i just don't know that it's
it's change and i'm not trying to get
all the credit in the world for patrick
mahomes
to patrick martial but you know it takes
us revolutionizing attitudes
but yeah you know what i was thinking
about this earlier today
and and not in a football context just
in general
you know it takes a a certain kind of
a personality to say why not
why not let's give it a try and see if
it happens
and in general uh those who have those
personalities the hot in the nfl
the higher they climb the more they
repress
that spontaneous that original
thinking okay let's go for it type of
mindset they
tend to blend in and say this won't work
i mean as recently as a couple of years
ago
i remember the former coach uh i think
it was
i think he did say i think it was marvin
uh marvin lewis when
his team lost to baltimore and uh lamar
jackson
ran for many many yards and he said well
he can't do that all year
you know he okay lamar jackson he
carried
last year he carried the ball like 12
times a game
gave you about 1200 yards 1100 1200
yards right yeah
well maybe you didn't think other
quarterbacks could do that but he did it
cam newton you're not going to be able
to run like that and run over people
because you're not going to last well
he's in his ninth year in the league
and he's been injured not from running
but from other injuries
but he still runs and runs over people
patrick mahomes you can't do
yes you can so maybe
these personalities are these these
types these stubborn
nfl personalities are starting to be
pushed aside a little bit
and people are looking at it saying yes
you can do the rpo with the nfl
yes you can have a quarterback who runs
and passes
give it a shot hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports